here's what you do you take you up paper
clip right and remember let's think back
to accenture too and also you know
contention with students when they're
dead lockers our circle is the paw
traced out by a point that moves
equidistant from a central point right
so all you need is something should be
your equal distance which is my paper
clip and you did something else to be
your central point okay so I guess I'll
for my circle
and I yes on the assignment think about
it okay so what I'm going to do is you
see is i will put down by central
motoring uncommon distance and i'm going
to prepare by setting so and then I say
well I want the lockers to the ark
senior any practice right Oh My Luck is
to be all outside today so so sorry we
doing properly
yeah if you know what you're doing it
feel pretty good that was really badly
done to the treasure and actually if you
have a naughty grab our summers and
because this one actually sort of sucks
in that will if you if you hold it down
and do too hard you can get a pretty
sweet so there's one of and then you
sort of have to lift up here and join
the other half that's pretty good way
like this and that's literally it's
literally the second time I thought that
in about three months that is the last
time I had to go this you can obviously
create a substantially being a circle if
you use cheap paper clips but that's
pretty big and that's about the you know
that roll of tape size that I was
talking about you're pretty much on
there luckily for you guys I have a
whole bunch of paper clips to lend out
if you want one today so not i'm
fortunate out of 24 but i do it quite a
few so I just if you can t secret thank
you very much